this is where it all began for the trump
family
a real estate empire fame fortune
and then the highest office in the land
hi donald john trump
but could the dealings which took place
in those buildings
now be the undoing of the former
president
this man is alan weiselberg chief
financial officer of the trump
organization
a loyal servant to the family for almost
half a century
he wore handcuffs as a court heard the
charges
against him a scheme to defraud
conspiracy and tax avoidance on 1.7
million dollars of income
allegations more serious than anyone
expected
the trump organization says they're
politically motivated
this case should have never been brought
it is a political prosecution political
prosecutions
where people are targeted criminally
because the prosecutors disagree with
their political beliefs
happen in corrupt countries it does not
happen in america
trump remains coy about his ambitions
going forward
he's been visiting the border wall this
week already positioning himself
for a potential presidential run in
2024.
the question is whether this and other
probes into his company
will put a premature end to those
aspirations
possibly he it might embolden him he
tends to have
that kind of a personality historically
and he
is used to doing things with no
consequences
so it's unlikely he will be chastened
by this and he loves publicity much will
depend on whether prosecutors can put
enough pressure on weisselberg
to turn him into an informant donald
trump himself hasn't been charged in
this instance
but it remains extraordinary that the
company of a man who was in the white
house less than six months ago
is being pursued in this way the former
president
said in a statement the charges are a
political witch-hunt
and dividing our country like never
before but for a man who has survived
two impeachments
he may view this as just another
inconvenience
martha kellner sky news washington d.c